enfin la guerre entre l'iran et l'irak
elle s'intensifie de jour en jour et
cela donne ces images souvent cruel
jean-marc il aux images irakienne
victime d'iraniennes comme cet enfant
soldat de 15 ans à peine tombé cette
semaine sur le front d'une guerre
interdite aux journalistes mais qui a
fait officiellement trois cent mille
morts en deux ans l'offensive aurore
lancé voilà six jours par les rangs lui
at elle permis de s'emparer de 300
kilomètres carrés de territoire irakien
peut-être mais pour l'irak ces images
montrent quelques-uns des 4000
prisonniers que bagdad affirme avoir
fait cette semaine
image iranienne cette fois
l'enthousiasmé révolutionnaire islamique
à téhéran fêtait hier le quatrième
anniversaire de la chute du shah ce
jeune homme est le fils de l'imam
khomeiny lit le message de son père
l'iran chiite est aussi puissant que
tous les pays arabes réunis
l'iran ne se bat plus pour recouvrer son
territoire c'est chose faite selon
téhéran
mais pour punir les dirigeants syriens
saddam hussein et le parti baassiste ses
enfants partiront peut être demain vers
le front pour avoir l'honneur leur vie
ton de reprendre kerbala
la ville sainte des chiites d'irak mais
c'est bien sûr devant l'ambassade
américaine que c'est arrêter la
manifestation comme mes mots ration
d'une révolution populaire prisonnière
du clergé chiite pour lequel l'amérique
reste le grand satan alors même qu'en
coulisses des institutions financières
officielle iranienne négocie
discrètement avec washington
le paiement d'indemnités pour les biens
américains confisqué par un régime qui
la semaine dernière
choisissez de frapper aussi le petit
parti communiste iranien l'ofce son
ministre français des relations
extérieures est en ce moment en irak
la france s'est rangé sans ambiguïté
derrière miracle face à l'iran